The thing that makes
this mean shift tracking
is essentially what the model is and
how we compare them.
So, we've got this initial
area that we want to track and
we have to choose what
the model is going to be.
And in mean shift what we do is
we choose a feature space that is
the quantized color space.
So, what that means is that we
carve up the different RGB
values into a histogram.
So it's written as a 1D histogram here,
but
it's typically a three
dimensional histogram.
R, G and B.
You might carve R up into four bins,
G up into four bins,
B up into say four bins.
That'd be how many bins together?
4 times 4 times 4?
1,000,090, no.
64, okay,
in which case you have a 64 bin
histogram and at every point
within that region you take its color
and you put it in the right bin.
And that would give you
your probability histogram
which you can think of as a PDF
of the color over that region.
That's the representation of the region
that we're going to try to track.